on this absolute mess of a day
uh we mentioned earlier that during the
riot at the capitol there was a woman
who was draped in a
trump flag who was trying to climb into
some other section
of the of the building and
she was shot she was shot in the neck
and it looked really bad she was wheeled
out
on a stretcher there's now a report from
newsbusters that the woman
has died there was an eyewitness account
take a listen
how did you get that on your hand well
we had stormed into the
the chambers inside and there was a
young lady who
rushed through the windows a number of
police and secret service were saying
get back
get down get out of the way she didn't
need the call and as we kind of raced up
to grab people and pull him back
they shot her in the neck and she fell
back on me and started saying she was
fine it's cool
and then she started kind of like moving
weird and blood was coming out of her
mouth and neck and nose and i don't know
if she's alive or dead anymore
so that was hours ago at this point we
don't know i mean
there is just so much misinformation
going around right now but we're finally
getting you know some
legit sources coming out and suggesting
the woman may have dodged at the very
least she would be
in critical condition very very very sad
stuff
because you you have to ask
whatever i mean even i hope she is still
alive even if she is for what
for what what was the what was achieved
by this the action at the capitol was
condemned by
trump himself uh it uh
did not stop the certification of a
biden it'll certainly be used as a
pretext
for more draconian measures passed
against conservatives
it uh what did it show what did it
accomplish
what was the end game i saw some people
on social media were saying
it was as if it was as if when you you
saw the people they break into the
capital
and all the legislators free in the old
days of revolutions you would declare a
new government right then and there and
you'd say
here we are you know it's the french
french revolution or something or in
cuba or the
castro is storming in and saying we're
the government now
but what happened at this riot was
basically nothing went in
a woman was shot by the police and then
uh
you know they kind of got some funny
pictures in nancy pelosi's office
and then what it was just a sort of
exasperation
and that but that's it for what why
would you lose your life over that
if you you know if you're going to risk
your life you have to have a worthy goal
in mind
there has to be a good reason for it and
a good strategy and a good plan and it
seems as though
none of that was here and it's not just
you know you're only going to hear now
for the next
i don't know eon you're going to hear
that the right is violent and the left
isn't violent at all and of course those
of us
who remember 2020 will know that that's
not accurate
at all but and those of us who look and
see conservatives say this is awful
trump himself
says this is awful but
it's not just this it's not just the
capital
it's not just the pipe bomb found at the
republican national committee
it's not just the demonstrations that in
georgia or kansas or wherever
it's not just even blm which torched
how many cities in our country for six
months it's not even just
antifa who were participating in the
torching of cities
it's it seems like it's everywhere
nancy this was just a few days ago nancy
pelosi's home
was apparently vandalized not not by
conservatives it seems it seems as
though they were vandalized by
by uh left wingers this was going around
it says someone wrote
you know pig's head left a pig's head
there and wrote uh
cancel rent two thousand dollars we want
everything
anarchist symbol anarchist symbol would
be a antifa symbol so you got the left
wingers
going against them
just a political chaos so you're seeing
a breakdown within the parties
and then you're seeing an increase in
in violence and the strangest thing of
all to me
is it didn't seem to
do very much i i almost wonder we've
talked about this on this show a lot
this government our our system right now
is
is administered basically by the
bureaucracy
so presidents come and go but the
bureaucrats stick around and they kind
of do whatever they want and sometimes
presidents can tinker here and there and
you know
especially if there's unified government
the senate can do this thing or that but
really the most powerful people in the
country are the bureaucrats and this was
a system designed
100 years ago by more than that now
by woodrow wilson grown up under
franklin roosevelt and then you know
just grown and grown over time lbj
contributed to this and that
administrative state has grown
and it it occurred to me if congress
weren't there you know if
you could storm those of congress it
doesn't actually disrupt all that much
in the actual practice of government
they'll go and they'll have the vote
later and appear they're going to just
certify
biden as the president-elect
and there doesn't appear to be anything
that anyone's going to do about it then
there's going to be a big blame game
and they're all going to blame trump
even though he condemned it they're
going to blame all the conservatives
even though they condemned it and
they're going to completely forget about
blm and they're not going to say a word
about it
and that will go on with
with rising national animosity you know
i was not alive in 1968 but i've read a
lot of history books
there was a lot of political violence
back in the 1960s
they assassinated one president another
presidential candidate civil rights
leader
and you you just looking back now as
someone who didn't live through it i
thought that could never happen here
well there was some violence hope
there's not more of it hope people heed
president trump's
call hope president i hope big tech lets
people retweet his call for peace
i i hope the tensions simmer down now
when we fix this system
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video